hello and thank you for joining us for
today's presentation
part of our agilent cell analysis global
conference
i'm susie valdez of the labyrinth and
i'll be moderating for today's
event so let's get started before we
begin i want to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
and we encourage you to participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click send we will answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
simply click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen i now present
today's speaker dr sachin katial
an assistant professor in the department
of pharmacology
and therapeutics at the university of
montetoba
and senior scientist at the research
institute in oncology
and hematology at cancer care manitoba
canada for a complete biography on dr
katyal
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr cartiel you may now begin your
presentation
welcome sir
thank you very much for that kind
introduction
today we're just going to go over some
of our recent data
where we've instituted some new high
troopa dna damage analysis
methodology looking at
synergistic drug combinations that we
can employ
to treat malignant brain tumors so
what we're looking at primarily are
astrocytoma which is in the frontal
cortex of the brain and medulloblastoma
which is a childhood cerebellar
malignancy that's all quite common
actually in children
so in the central nervous system these
two tumors are
considered very malignant so
medulloblastoma is an invasive
cerebellar tumor which is 10 times more
common in children
and it is thought that they emanate from
immature or embryonal
progenitors in contrast glioblastoma
multiformat or
astrocytomyosite as i refer to it is a
highly aggressive form of
brain tumor it accounts for 30 percent
of all
tumors of the cns and 80 of all brain
malignancies
and it's thought to arise from
dysregulated astrocytes
so current therapies in both tumor types
include
often surgery followed by radiation and
also chemotherapy
and these chemotherapies vary depending
on the tumor type uh medulloblastoma
versus gluoblastoma
primarily in glioblastomatomazolamide
this is a dna alkalinity agent that's
used
and is the second line topoteken is
known to be used
in medulloblastoma of interest and this
is platinum are often used
um now medullobustoma does have a better
uh treatment rate compared to
glioblastoma uh
30 to 40 percent of patients however do
die due to recurrence
whereas glioblastoma multi-form has a
five-year survival rate of only about
two percent
one thing that is common amongst both
tumors is that
survivors suffer from neurocognitive
defects due to the side effects of the
drugs
and these defects are much more
pronounced
in children of medulloblastoma because
those are the formative years
and and those children who do survive
will encounter those those defects for
the
length of their the rest of their lives
however
recurrence is very high due to
chemoradio resistant tumor cells and one
of the aspects that we're looking at
is whether this resistance is due to an
enhanced amount of
repair capacity to resolve dna damage
due
to chemotherapy now this slide
is a very busy one but it's really meant
to
uh give an idea of the different
uh types and the breadth of chemotherapy
uh that are used in in in treating a
variety of malignancies
and and the main take-home message here
is that in
in over 98 percent of chemotherapies the
goal
is ultimately to affect dna to instill
some sort of dna damage and overwhelm
the cell's capacity to repair such
damage
so as to induce cell death
and so to to understand how
chemotherapeutics work on dna
and how we have uh uh this uh
effort of cells to repair dna uh damage
in order to institute salt survival we
need to understand
the different types of dna repair
pathways that are engaged
and so the cell has distinct dna repair
pathways
to repair specific types of dna lesions
now the you know we think of these
pathways as being very linear but there
is a lot of crosstalk amongst them
but this is a more simplified view of
how dna damage occurs and
and some of the most pronounced lesions
that occur
are dna single strand breaks which
engages the dna single strand break
repair or basic vision repair pathways
we can have bulky lesions which engage
the nucleoside excision repair pathway
and what's uh most commonly uh known
are are referred to are the double
strand breaks which engages the double
strand break repair machinery uh
two types of repair paths
uh occur you have non-homologous end
joining
and more commonly known um and and quite
a bit in the news
the last five ten years it's a molecular
combination repair
and so dna strand breaks induce
initially a cellular dna
damage response or we call it ddr
response
and this is orchestrated most often by
the atm
protein and so the atm kinase
is the pi3 related kinase which goes on
to
phosphorylate a number of downstream
effectors
and those include p53 check two akt
cap1 and it's about to involve over 1100
different effectors that affect the cell
cycle
that can affect survival that ultimately
affecting
repair but also affect metabolism
and so one of the ways we know when a a
dna break is is induced
is we can use an antibody against gamma
h2ax
which after immunostaining marks
sites of dna double strand breaks so
it's one way that tells us where the
break is occurring
but if you look at this cartoon h2ax is
also
involved in the early parts of the dna
repair process
so these indicate sites of potential
data repair
but on top of that we can use
biochemical techniques to tell us
what types of downstream effects have
been mediated by
atm this includes looking at check two
phosphorylation
arcterium 15 phosphorylation of p53
furthermore we can look at atm specific
effects
primarily cap one phosphorylation which
tells us where the uh how well our or
how much the atm pathway is engaged
so we have in front of us a lot of
biochemical and molecular techniques
that can illustrate what types of dna
repair
events are occurring now
when once we get past that dna damage
response
uh effect ultimately the cell wants to
repair
and so for simplicity's sake we're going
to be
looking at primarily being a double
strand brake repair and single strand
brake repair
and so as i mentioned in the double
strand brake repair pathways
we have two different modes we have
homologous recombination repair
which primarily occurs when
dna is undergoing replication and then
outside of that replicative phase
we have the non-homologous end joining
which involves end joining factors
that bring together broken dna and
ultimately reseal it
to complement these two we have dna
single strand break repair
this is a part driven process where parp
will
sense that dna single strand break or
nick
and we'll recruit the extra cc-1
scaffolding protein
which brings along a number of end
processing factors and ligases
that ultimately resolve these breaks
now to give context of the occurrence of
these types of breaks
it's very often thought that irradiation
causes
dna double strand breaks and it does
however the ratio of seeing a single
strand breaks the double strand breaks
is 40 to 1 upon irradiation
so it's very important to understand the
context
of the damage that's being induced and
the different types of breaks that are
being induced
but in the context of chemotherapy and
with the advent now of different dna
damage repair inhibitors
there's a thought that we may be able to
improve chemotherapy success
and possibly use dna damage repair
inhibitors
as a way to chemosensitize tumors
and so for um illustrating this purpose
i'm giving you a schematic of
topoisomerase one inhibitors
so topoisomerase one is involved in
changing dna topology uh during dna
uh transcription or replication and so
are there there are dna topoisomerase
inhibitors
camp the thetans uh such as topetik and
arenate can
and also there are non-campuses and
moieties that are also involved
and as you can see in this slide uh a
number of
uh dna repair pathways including single
strand break repair
double strand brake repair including
homologous recombination
are engaged depending on whether the the
dna is undergoing transcription
or undergoing replication and so we can
if we were to inhibit some of those
repair pathways
so the this is down below we're talking
about dna
damage repair inhibitors we may boost
the effectiveness of some of these
topoisomerase inhibitors or top
unpoisoned
so the idea here is can we find ways
where we look at
different chemotherapeutics and dna
damage repair inhibitors
and and look at rational combinations
and find effective ways to
measure readouts using techniques that
are
effectively measure dna damage
that occurs in the cell current
techniques are cumbersome
they're actually quite old a lot of them
were developed in the 1980s
and and there are very few newer
techniques
uh that can look at this type of
combination
and and one of the most common
old-school techniques as i like to call
it is the alkali comet assay
which can measure dna damage at a single
cell level
we can look at endogenous dna damage we
can also look at induction of dna damage
denovo
but we can also look at repair dna
damage by sampling different time points
following damage or time after damage
and measure repair rates now the reason
why this is called a common acid
is because at a single cell level we are
looking for the extent
of dna in the comet tail so this comet
arises due to damage dna
that once you apply an electrical
current those damaged fragments will
migrate away
from the nuclear dna so
it will form a bit of a trail or a tail
and and when you visualize these cells
under a microscope they appear like a
comet
and so the more damage the more
damaged dna in the tail and we can
actually
measure how much dna in the intensity
and the length
of dna in that tail and come up with a
value
that gives us a relative amount of
damage
and so we call that a tail moment and
again it's a microscopy based
image analysis where we're looking at
the percentage of dna in the tail
multiply the distance between the means
of the head and the tail
and so as i say the old school way is
for every time point
sample we're looking at uh in in say a
24 wall plate we'll harvest those cells
put them on the slide
we will lice those cells wash them put
them in a
comet as a slide vessel
apply an electrical current we will uh
add a cyber green to counter stain the
dna
and image them under the scope and then
we will manually count
this dna damage or these comets
and score these and come up with a value
and there's some auto
uh semi-automated software where we
point
uh our mouths and click on the cell and
it gives us a readout
but as you can imagine this can be very
cumbersome and
and to sit there and count hundreds of
comments per slide
when you want to look at the different
combinations of chemotherapeutics
and dna damage repairing inhibitors both
in single double triple or multiple
combinations
you can imagine how many tens dozens or
hundreds of combinations one would
require to count
and this is where some of the new
techniques have come out
which i like to call high tropic comet
using a 96 well-based comet slide
and some of the new technology and
analysis capabilities
some of the biotech instrumentation
that is available and namely we use the
citation 5
where we work with biotech to develop
criteria and analysis techniques to
make a semi-automated combat analysis
possible
and so using common assay imaging
analysis
via the citation 5 and gen 5 software
allows us to have an improved way of
imaging
and analysis of
multiple combinations of
dna damage repair inhibitors and
chemotherapeutics
so we get the benefits of automated
imaging which
includes using pre-defined library
definitions
which allows us to have higher
throughput capabilities
but also we have built-in cellular
analysis capabilities
where we don't have to export and import
images into image j
to do individual cell a cumbersome cell
analysis
analysis of all comments are captured in
one
image it's object objective it's free of
user bias and fatigue
what you see is what you get the system
does the analysis for you
you're not what we say searching for
comments where you're
looking to click it's not dependent on
the user
so it becomes non-biased
so we have this capability now
to do this novel high throughput comet
analysis
and and so this is a image readout
of a common athlete slide where each
individual
well is represented in each little box
there
and so as we uh
encounter more dna damage you start to
see
a transition from a no damage where you
have nice
round nuclei or nucleoid as we call them
in this case
to when you have a situation of higher
dna damage
where you start seeing longer tails that
can be imaged
and a lot of this analysis and and
effort was developed by
two student members in my lab asha sinha
and marina masta's art
but also a lot of work was put in by
brad larston from biotech
who really helped make some of this
automated analysis
happen so
initial proof of principle analysis
allowed us to start
doing quantitative image capturing
so again using a topoisomerase inhibitor
camtasia
we could start seeing an increase in
induced dna damage going from
a lower concentration to a higher
concentration and so using
2.5 times objective and the gfp channel
we could develop image montages stitch
them together
and do a automated analysis
and so this analysis will is
two parts where you're using a dual mask
identification
the initial mask is to identify the
comet head
so it delineates the head and then the
second mass will
delineate the top comet tail and then in
doing so
the a system can calculate the amount of
dna in the tail
and therefore come up with the tail
moments
and if you look on the right hand side
when we do the validation studies where
we're comparing
uh more manual methods versus the gen 5
analysis
the comparison uh stats are quite tight
and they agree very very well
and so building our resource around
this methodology we put together our
suite
where we've got our citation 5 cell
imaging system
combined with our gen 5 image prime
software and we've been able now to
increase our high throughput capacity by
using
a biospa 8 automated incubator
and in this case we're not really even
using the incubator portion but we're
using the
automated plate capacity so that we can
switch between different slides
without very much user interface needed
so we can increase our analysis so
if you're looking at 96 wells on that
comet slide
times eight we're getting close to 800
uh analysis all at one time
we've combined this now with an el-406
washer dispenser we've got a multi-flo
fx multi-mold dispenser
and also hamilton star liquid handling
which allows us to truly use a more
automated approach to
institute this high-throughput comet
platform
combined this can increase our n number
we can then increase multiple
combinations
and use different cell lines conditions
and time points which allows for a more
thorough analysis
of dna repair responses in different
models
and as you can imagine you know
generally if just to give you some
context
24 or 36 comet slides
then in a more traditional manner takes
us about two
three days of hands-on
time and finally analysis whereas now we
can do
800 individual common analysis
in a matter of six to eight hours so you
can see
we've got a scenario where
we can really boost your throughput and
enhance
our analysis and so
this also allows us to start doing
things like cooperativity studies which
we previously could not do
so this is the trevogen common athlete
slide
it's a 96 well glass slide
which will carry
our agarose and cell mixture as
beads and we do all of our lysis watch
steps
and electrophoresis on the slide as you
can imagine scenario where you could
have
drug a and drug b in this case we're
looking at a topoisomerase inhibitor top
ot can
combine with a parp inhibitor olap rib
and we can then in this case look at 64
different combinations
using different drug concentrations to
do this analysis
and in doing that comparison looking at
topotech and olap rib
where you're co-treating cells and these
are glioblastoma cells for one hour
we can start looking at synergy analysis
of
analyzing the drug responses both
individually and in combination with
different drug concentrations
and we can extend these to other type
drug classes
topotecant is a second line therapeutic
used to treat
glioblastoma in certain cases
temozolomide is the drug of choice the
gold standard
and again we can look at temozolomide
treatment over a 24-hour period
with and without uh different
concentrations of elaborate
and start looking at synergy analysis
um even from a biochemical standpoint we
can use a more pure double strand break
inducing agent
something called neocarxinostatin and
combined with elaborate
look at dna damage responses
and so this allowed us now to ask
specific questions more about
comparisons
between different cms tumors and amongst
different lines within those tumors
and the the idea here is can we
find different combinations of dna
damage repair inhibitors
that would indicate that which could be
maybe possibly upregulated
that that show us alternate dna repair
pathways that may promote resistance
to dna damaging therapeutic agents so in
using these different inhibitors and in
combination with
therapeutic agents can we identify
combinations that may better sensitize
tumor cells to therapeutics
so we're using dna repair and
genotoxicity responses to evaluate
combinations of
different therapeutics different dna
repair inhibitors
in different cns tumor types and
different lines within common cns tumors
and in this case for this proof of
concept study we were comparing
glioblastoma with metroblastoma cell
lines
and so this work initially was
spearheaded by marina in the lab
and so an initial analysis was just to
compare
uh different two different measurable
stomach saw lines where
we were not treating these cells and
then treating them
with uh camp disease and then just
looking at our
initial committal analysis and so this
is just a simple
four treatment analysis looking at two
different cell lines
and and this is typically how you would
uh
look at analyzing your comet tail
moments
you count your comma tails and you would
then express them as an average or a
mean
comma tail moment on a graph just to
look at
relative damage amongst the two lines
and as you can see here in our
concentration of campuses and being used
the d283 tumor line
uh is less sensitive to the dowie
medulloblastoma tumor line but now when
we expand this
and start including different dna damage
inhibitors
this is where the power of the
methodology really comes through
where we can use camtasia in combination
with different
uh dna damage repair inhibitors both in
single r
double or even in triple and start
looking at
unique damage repair responses
and you start seeing patterns developing
particularly with the parp inhibitor
where
in combination with campus these and we
see a multifold induction of increased
dna damage in both the dowey line and
the d283 line
and if we start interrogating these
individually we can start seeing
at individual differences amongst the
lines here
but we can take this further and look at
the a different dna damaging agents so
looking at an alkylating agent methyl
methyl methane sulfonate mms combined
with
again our different dna damage repair
inhibitors the parp inhibitor the atm
inhibitor
and another related inhibitor atm is
gene apk
and in combination we start seeing
unique
signatures coming through strictly using
dna damage and dna damage repair as a
readout
again breaking these up amongst the two
different lines
we start seeing differences amongst the
lines where
specific sensitivities are emerging
with different combinations and then
teasing these responses out we can start
asking biological
questions how do
different repair inhibitors affect um
cell survival viability sensitivity
and here is an instance where we're
finding that
part inhibitors are much more effective
in sensitizing the dowie medullbostoma
line
um compared to the d283
and in in conjunction with a
topoisomerase inhibitor
we find that a parp inhibitor can
synthesize
themselves by five-fold uh uh
and enhance their that dna damage
induced cell death effect whereas in the
d283
we find very little effect of olaparib
on those cell types and starting to then
extend this further looking at cellular
viability analysis
comparing the two different lines we we
show
that uh the topotecan
is much more able to sensitize staui
cells
d283 and then again that's uh
greatly enhanced once you add uh
dna damage repair inhibitors in the
dowie compared to d283
using the citation 5 we can also
use particular protocols looking at
nuclear area which enables us to do
cell viability outside their salt growth
assays
such techniques are are likely to be
used
in presentations that will be following
mine
uh both with uh kirkwood massive
uh that's true mcmanus and navji chandra
they're going to be talking about some
of these techniques in their
ensuing presentations but in this case
here we're using
the nuclear area assay to look at growth
and and again uh and instituting
using alapa with topic and we can see
uh clear growth differences amongst the
two different cell lines
and again taking this further to
different analysis techniques
and in combining with our bio spa eight
we can do this
in a kinetic basis where the system
can analyze growth over time
using different concentrations and
combinations
of these drugs
and so further we can institute cell
death assays using
different cell viability and cell death
uh dyes and again using this
in a kinetic basis
and so we were interested in in looking
at what's
mediating this clear difference between
the two medullobastroma cell lines
and so we perform rna-seq analysis
uh doing a triplicate analysis amongst
our dowie
and our d283 medullostoma cells and then
using the lens of dna damage repair
um in in our readout we identified a
number of dna damage repair genes that
were potentially up and down regulated
amongst the different cell lines
and then taking this to the validation
stage we went directly
to western analysis where we were we
were able to validate 13 of these genes
as being differentially
induced and again the most sensitizing
of the agents uh in terms of dna damage
repair inhibitors
in in dowie compared to d283 was part
and what we identified was despite
no differences in harp
um genetics in terms of deletions or
mutations
we found about a 80 reduction
in the harp in part expression
in daoi which could likely account for
the differential effect of the parp
inhibitor
in dowie compared to d283 there's less
park in daoi and therefore that drug has
a greater effect
on park compared to d283 which
readily expresses ample amounts of parp
which would mean that you would need
more inhibitor to have any sort of
effect
and so in our mind we took a very
simple concept that's
the common assay we use a high
throughput
uh analysis technique where we could
start interrogating different dna damage
repair inhibitors
and comparing that with different
chemotherapy
modes and we identified
a cellular effect the difference with
particular combinations
and took that through to a validation
stage where we identified
a key genie repair protein
that may be mediating this effect
now just switching gears uh we're
looking
at a analysis
analogous assay and i already mentioned
the gamma h2x foci assay
now this assay uses a
gamma-astrix antibody which marks
different dna breaks again
a very uh old-school technique where
every break that's marked in the in the
in the nucleus and they they are
actually look
like little aggregates or we call them
foci
each foci represents a dna double strand
break
sites and so you can imagine a scenario
where
every nuclei that you are imaging and
then ultimately counting
can be very low throughput where you're
sitting there
and counting each individual foci and
you can develop
scripts where each individual cell can
be counted in a more automated way
but again it requires you to
import and export these images to image
j
and and can be very time consuming
sitting there and compiling
different individual foci and as again
as you can imagine
you would want to count a number of
cells per
well a number of treatments a number of
cell types
it can become very laborious to do
such analysis and so again we're taking
our biotech instrumentation putting it
to work for us
again working with brad larson and
asha and marine in the lab we came up
with
a automated high throughput method of
analy
analyzing gamma h2x foci
and this takes advantage again of the
image reading
imaging capability of the citation 5
combined with some very good reagents
and ultimately
some multi mask
analysis techniques to come up with our
foci analysis
and by doing so we were able to expand
our ability to do this analysis to look
at
functional cooperativity and this
enables us to understand the dynamics of
dna damage repair
again dna double strand breaking out
a a double strand breaks
undergoes repair through two different
modes as i mentioned
non-amelica's end joining homologous
recombination
and depending what stage of the cell
cycle the cell
is in when that damage is incurred and
that repair
is ultimately undergoing
different nodes of the cell cycle will
predominate and we can harness
different uh markers for the cell cycle
and also markers for hr or an nhdj
mediated repair to understand how repair
is occurring in the cell
so in addition to gamma hvac analysis
which allows us
to to mark dna double strand breaks
we can use antibodies against rad51
which will
uh tell us when a a cell is undergoing
hr mediated repair
or 53bp1 which allows us to understand
when the cell's undergoing
non-homologous and joint immediate
repair but in addition
we can do cell cycle distribution
analysis using
nuclear intensity and also
different cell cycle markers
again to mask along with
our different dna damage repair
antibodies to understand what type of
repair
and when in the cell cycle this occurs
on
this uh repair is undergoing
again then using nuclear staining
methodology
we can combine it with cell viability
analysis
and also use an antibody against anti
single stranded dna
which has is previously shown to mark
sites undergoing cells undergoing
apoptosis so we can combine all these
different
analytical tools to come up with a one
stop shop way of
doing uh analysis of dynamics of dna
damage repair
and cell death and so working with brad
we first tackled dna gamma h2ax
foci analysis and coming up with
our multi-masking
methodology we can first put our object
mask around the nucleus and then our
secondary mask
using gen 5 image prime allows us to put
masks around all the labeled foci
that are labeled following gamma a6
antibody
staining and then
our secondary independent analysis can
determine foci number per image
and so then by taking foci number per
image
we can then calculate the number of foci
per nuclei
now this was our initial uh way of
tackling this problem but since then uh
and that
enhancements to the uh the masking
protocol allows to look at
individualized
foci per cell where now we can start
analyzing each cell each individual
number
of foci per cell and come up with a
readout
and so you can imagine scenarios where
you can have
untreated cells and you'll only see
maybe one two or three foci
which are typical in uh replicating
cells you'll have all those
f phase dependence gamma h2x foci
which are indicative of different sites
of replication
you can also image low damage medium
damage and high damage and
and nothing special about that as you
increase your damage your number of foci
will go out but you can also have
situations where the damage is so high
that there's so many sites um that could
be gamma a6
positive those numbers start going
up and up and up where you get
a situation of having pad nuclear gamma
h2x
foci where the entire nucleus flights up
so the readouts we're interested are
in the number of foci per cell
and so some very quick analyses we can
start doing combinatory analysis
looking again at drug a versus drug b
and start characterizing
the average number of foci per cell or
we can look at the percentage of cells
with a certain number of foci per cell
so we always like to look at cells
greater than free foci
because typically uh cells uh
have always one two three uh s phase
dependent foci per cell
and so here's a proof of concept where
as we
increase our concentration of our
harp inhibitor olap rib along with our
topoisomerase one inhibitor topotecan we
start seeing
increased percentage of cells with
greater than three foci per cell but
again we can also look at
number of foci per cell and so you'll
always have
percentage of cells that don't incur
many gamma strikes
foci and percentage of cells that
include
that incur a great number but here you
see in our heat map
as we increase our harp inhibitor
and our topic summaries when inhibitor
in combination
we start seeing increased uh gamma h2x
foci as
indicative by the darker squares in our
heat map
and so well we took this another step
further
to provide a proof of principle we
started using dna repair deficient lines
a very commonly used line is the mu59
glioblastoma cell line mu59j
being a dna pk deficient line so dnapk
is involved in the non-homologous end
joining
process of dna double star break repair
and the mu 59k
which is the dnapk proficient
and so when we use this these cell lines
and we started instituting uh the use of
a topoisomerase inhibitor
first looking at gamma extract as the
readout we could see
in our deficient line
we start seeing less repair as indicated
by
gamma h2ax in our
deficient compared to our proficience
and
we but we see an increase in uh
gamma-e-strict pan-nuclear foci
indicating so much more damage
that's being unrepaired compared to our
proficient
but very nice to see we
are our validation here where in
our deficient it's our non-homologous
and joint deficient mu59j line
we start seeing a reduction in 53bp1
foci stain
so 53b bp1 would be an indicator
of non-homologous and joining activity
whereas
we see an increase in rad51 or hr
dependent activity
being enhanced in the non-homologous and
joining
deficient line when we look at the
proficient
we see 53bp1 foci being
predominant compared to rad51 although
rad51 is there
and that is consistent with the fact
that
rad51 dependent homologous recombination
is only occurring
when the cell dna is undergoing
replication
whereas the 53 bp1 dependent foci which
is in
uh indicative of non-homologous and
joining activity
uh occurs throughout the entire cell
cycle
and is more often more predominant as a
repair choice
so again proof of principle this showing
us that
we are getting uh
what we would expect and the types of
dna damage repair
arms in it during
when damages incurred now using
a variety of nuclear analysis
and cell cycle markers
we were able to even look at
cell cycle distribution of when uh this
damages incurred
and so using this is the same
assay using the same um readout
we were able to show uh the percentage
of cells
uh in different phases of the cell cycle
and again consistent with what we
thought
we should see in the deficient line
we see a preponderance of increased cell
damage resulting in an increase in sg2
phase
of the deficient compared to the
proficient
we use another damage type new yorkers
in the statin which is again a much more
pure dna double strand brake inducer
very similar readout in the
deficient we see a preponderance in
a rad 51 hr dependent foci
whereas in the proficient we see an
increase in 53 bp1
both sides so
now taking this now back to
using clinically relevant drugs
in glioblastoma we wanted to look at how
these cells respond
to temozolomide which is a dna
alkylating agent
and then the second second line
chocotican
and so temozolomide induces
a number of base modifications which
engage
either base excision repair or mgmt
which may ultimately feed back into base
decision repair
now again basic scissor and repair is a
single strand brake repair pathway
however cells these cells being tumor
cells and being highly replicative
unrepaired dna single strand breaks when
they encounter
a replication fork will collapse into a
dna double strand break
and so again looking at dna double
strand break repair
is particularly topical
and we were interested in combining
those two chemotherapeutics
again with different types and classes
of parp inhibitors
and so parp inhibitors are very well
known
in the homologous recombination sphere
looking at bracket deficient breast
cancer
ovarian cancer endometrial cancer and is
now being used in clinical trials
in lung and prostate in colorectal
cancer
but we wanted to ask a number of
different types of parp inhibitors
including a more recently
uh developed one that's called
pramaparib which is known to
cross the blood-brain barrier using an
image-based analysis on our citation
five
in u-251 cells we were able to validate
that this pamaprib and these other topo
carp inhibitors are effective in
inhibiting
correlation levels so correlation is a
result
of um of carb activity
and by inhibiting parp you see reduction
in parlation
and parlation is often used uh to
activate base excision repair and other
double tram brake repair enzymes
and other cellular processes so in our
hands we show
by image-based analysis that parlation
is effectively inhibited with or without
dna damage with these parp inhibitors
and so we took this then to our assay
now this is where the power of the
automated
high throughput gamma hdx analysis comes
into play
where we can use different
concentrations with different
combinations of parp inhibitors
looking at our uh in this case
temozolomide
at different concentrations at different
time points
and and start looking at our average
gamma h2x and
foci that form and as you can see as we
increase
particular part concentrations and
different classes of harp
we start seeing an increase in gamma
h2ax foci forming
and we start seeing themes where
particular types of parp inhibitors
are more effective at inducing damage
compared to others
but what's very curious is when you look
at the higher concentrations
that heat map that signal actually goes
lower
and you would expect it to go higher
with increased damage
and that led us to think that perhaps
with the gamma h2x
fosi we are not picking up foci any
longer
perhaps we're picking up more
pan-nuclear foci
and indeed we do see an increase in
pan-nuclear
damage uh with those two olap and
pemapreg which is bmn673
again showing for two particular parp
inhibitors being more effective
at chemosensitizing temazolamide to
glioblastoma cell lines
but despite the fact that we see this
increase we feel that there was still
some foci or some cells not being
accounted for
and again this is where the power of the
the all-in-one approach
to this cell analysis comes into play
because
we can use our nuclear staining to also
measure
co-measure cell viability and so in this
case now we're looking to see
where do we see a reduction in the
signal in the heat map
where we see reduced cell viability and
again looking particularly at the bmn
673
as we increase our temperament
concentration
with bmn 673 we see reduced
cell viability consistent with an
increase in dna damage induced foci
and an increase in dna damage ultimately
resulting in dna damage induced cell
death
similar thing with the use of our topic
summaries inhibitor
as we increase dna damage we see more
and more
black so more gamma h2x
boats by forming but at the highest
levels of damage
we see light and that light is accounted
for
by the fact that we're seeing more
pan-nuclear damage
so we're seeing a greater amount of
damage more so than
can be picked up with foci and we see an
increase
in dna induced damage induced cell death
and we can apply cell synchronization in
these analyses where we start looking at
uh instituting different par
inhibitors with our different dna damage
types
and we start seeing differential effects
upon fault synchronization with the
amount of dna damage that's incurred
looking at both gamma h2ax and
gamma h2x 53bp1 foci
and rad51 foci which is then indicating
to us
at different phases of the cell cycle
what types of
dna damage repair arms are being used to
repair that damage
and finally we can also look at dna
damage as a measure of
cell cycle and amount of gamma h2ax that
are forming
at different uh stages of the cell cycle
so that we can see where that damage is
being incurred
and how much repair capacity
is is present
at different stages of the cell cycle
so what this allows us now and it
enables
a uh is for techniques to study
functional cooperativity
and we can apply this all-in-one
approach not only to just
live cells but just imagine in a
situation where we can use
patient-derived tumor microarrays
particularly
say in breast cancer where we use
neoadjuvant therapy
to reduce the tumor prior to to surgical
removal of the tumor
we could actually look at how well did
chemotherapy adjuvant chemotherapy work
in the tumor by using different cell
cycle markers
and gamma hyacks to decipher
where in the cell cycle those tumor
cells
ended up being in and what types of
damage
were incurred we can use utilize
such a high throughput gamut hvx
analysis
uh in drug screening look at fda drug
repurposing
we can do combination analysis and even
use it
in drug discovery again through a lens
of dna damage
again the chemotherapies mostly are dna
damage inducing
again we can use this all in one
approach so look at
gamma h2x dna damage and ultimate dna
damage
induced cell death we can do drug
responsiveness studies
and compare tumor versus normal cells so
we can look at
a effective dose and therapeutic windows
comparing
how well damaged induction
occurs in tumor cells and how
how toxic they may be in normal cells
and ultimately
this type of technique and methodology
could be used for both diagnostic
purposes
but even prognostication of how well
uh tumors are going to respond you can
imagine scenarios where
we can take live tumor results from
patients
and and do a multi-combination drug
analysis
and see how well this drug
these drugs or this drug combination is
able to
induce dna damage and do dna damage
profiling
so um i i believe the the development of
these techniques really opens up a lot
of doors
for both basic science and clinically
relevant
science and uh and even patient care
and i think the sky is the limit on on
using these
old school techniques in a high
throughput setting
for future fundamental and
clinical analysis so with that uh
i'd like to acknowledge members of my
lab particularly asha and marina
who've been the driving force for
instituting these
novel methodologies uh in our uh
science basic science and clinically
relevant research platforms
but also like to really um give a hat
off to
brad larson who uh really helped develop
uh and work with us he came to the lab
uh worked with us and our
uh instruments to develop these
techniques um
we had a very good collaboration with
brad i've had a number of technical
publications
in um with biotech on the biotech
website but on top of that we are now uh
proceeding with publication with
these techniques and some of uh our data
some of which
i showed that are unpublished but more
data that we're trying to
get published in in the coming months
been a very good and fruitful
collaboration i'd also like to
acknowledge our funders
and with that i'll take any questions
that may arise from my
presentation thank you
and thank you dr cathy all for that
informative presentation
we will now start the q a portion of
this webinar
if you have any questions you'd like to
ask please do so
now just click on that ask question box
located on the far left of your screen
so let's get started we already have
some questions
coming in dr patriot
so i see one here can cannabis
thc cbd can be used to treat
malignancies it's actually a very
interesting question we actually have a
project in a lab looking at
thc cbd treatment in breast cancer
because
breast cancer patients are amongst the
highest users of thc and cbd
amongst all cancer patients primarily
that use is more for
alleviation than symptoms and side
effect management
but a fundamental question that has
emerged is
can thc or cbd cause
or change the tumor itself can it
enhance dna damage was the question we
asked
and our preliminary data is actually
showing again using these very
techniques that i
uh just presented that so far pure thc
pure cbd
or combinations of whether twenty to one
ten to one
one to one one to ten or one to twenty
thpb
uh does not seem to induce any
additional dna damage
over normal thank you dr katiel
and dr katiala is it possible to expand
the hd comment assay to 384
well format we would love to be able to
do that
as i mentioned as i showed there was
that one
clear and red slide that's a trevigen
comet slide and that slide
has a especially made
where you have an image
image ready surface to hold
our cells that are mixed with agarose
and that ima
that those cells agros are mixed
together and they dry on that
clear area of the slide and then our our
light this watch
and electro frequencies occur on that
slide along with the imaging
our limitation is just on that slide
itself
that we only have a 96 well type slide
available and so trevogen makes that and
as far as i know they have not made a
384 well
uh format so you could take a 384 well
plate and then basically
plate four different 96 well slides and
then proceed from there
if you've got you know a hamilton or
even um
uh some other types of uh automated
liquid handling capabilities
it's not that difficult to do uh you
just start to just need to have a few
more manifolds to run the 96 well
fl traversing slides thank you dr
carville and i want to thank our
audience for these great questions we
have time for two more questions
what is the optimal concentration of
cells to add to each
well for the hc comet assays to get
robust analysis so you have to be very
careful you don't use too little or too
many
too little you're not going to get
enough n number too many
the comments are going to start to
overlap and it's going to give the
system trouble
to do the individual math so your
your goal is often to try to get between
20 to 30 000 cells per 100 microliters
on each well that's your optimal
concentration
and you can find um that those
concentrations
are specified in in different comet
assay
protocols including the ones we've
published both with biotech and
in some of my previous papers
thank you for that and is the gamma h2ax
image analysis assay you described
available for
download and use from biotech
yes so it's on the biotech website
brad and i have published a
tech app note on the biotech website uh
and um the the more detail about both
the technique
the and the analysis um and the
provisions of the assay
are in that uh tech application note on
the biotech website so it's a very good
resource
to find more details on how to use that
for your that technique
and even the common assay a high
throughput common essay for your
individual applications
dr cartier thank you again for your
presentation today
would you like to provide our audience
members with any final comments before
we close
um so i i again we're looking at a very
old-school technique but no new uses uh
in a high throughput manner i think it's
very powerful because it opens new doors
to uh combinatorial dna damage analysis
where we can now use these techniques
for a variety of both basic science or
our clinical uh research um and i
encourage you to explore
um this possibility um
you know at dna looking at dna damage
and chemotherapy
and thank you again dr sachin castillo
for sharing your work with us today
and thank you to all of our audience
members for your questions
and participation take care bye
bye